[Music]
welcome this afternoon to our talk on
Android security my name is Adrienne
work on Android security Shaolin will be
joining us in just a minute as well it's
going to be a bit of a whirlwind tour if
I talk too fast or Shaolin talks too
fast I apologize but there's really been
a lot going on in the world of security
on Android and Google Play over the last
year the last two years last five years
and so we're going to try to touch on
quite a bit of that as we go through
here today and give you the information
that you hopefully need and certainly
seem to want we've got a lot of people
here today pretty exciting what we're
going to cover is we'll talk a little
bit about the security services and from
their handoff and begin talking about
the core operating system and app
security so we'll dive right in
yesterday we heard mention of something
new exciting Google Play protect what is
Google Play protect the core of it is an
engine that we've built over the last
several years to protect all of the
devices in the Android ecosystem this
slide has grown year after year now we
talk about over two billion devices
around the world that are protected by
those services scanning over a billion
devices and checking over 50 billion
devices and the applications every
single day so incredible scale and the
reason that we have that scale because
we need it to be able to see what's
going on on an ecosystem that's on a
mass really almost the majority of
devices that are out there in the world
to be able to actually look at all of
that data of course requires
computational resources turns out Google
has quite a few of those we use just a
tiny sliver of them to look at the data
everyday over 20,000 dedicated
processors that are looking at that
application data analyzing it diving
deep into every single new application
that we find over 500,000 new
applications discovered every day and
trying to understand how they behave in
our environment how they behave out
there in the real world and what risks
they might pose for users now the reason
we do that of course is to protect users
and so one of the most important things
that we do is try to keep an eye on what
is the risk that users are being exposed
to clearly over the last few years what
we found is that users of Google Play
are in a much safer position they're
about 95 percent safer if they're
installing applications that come from
Google
and the reason is we're able to use data
that's gathered outside of google play
and then analyze that in the context of
an environment that's much more
controlled and so applications at the
time that they're uploaded we're able to
analyze them understand what's in there
and then make good guidance and provide
that kind of guidance but we also
provide those protections outside of
Google Play and so that's what we wanted
to show here is that over the last few
years we've been carefully tracking this
keeping an eye on what's going on and
making sure that users are being
protected from my perspective it's all
about the graphs but that's not really
how most people think about security
because most people aren't looking at
the entire ecosystem at once what they
want to know is am i safe and so that's
really what the announcement was
yesterday putting really in a brand
understanding that these protections are
there and making them more and more
visible to users but also that Google is
standing behind this protection right
it's saying Google is going to protect
you on your Android device and make sure
that we have the best protections in
place throughout the devices and so
that's really what we're focusing on how
do we do that we do that in a variety of
different ways we're investing in
increasing the intelligence the ability
to analyze what's going on on these
devices as well as what's going on
inside of these applications expanding
the scope of the types of protections
that we provide and also quite simply
switching from that graph mindset that
I've latched on to in my life into the
user mindset or what they want to know
is am I being protected right now
am I being protected what it is that it
is that Google is doing to look out for
me and so we've got a lot that we're
doing in terms of increasing user
visibility when I talk about that
increased protection one of the most
important things that we've learned is
that we can't do it all as humans right
when you're talking about 500,000 new
applications that are discovered and
analyzed every single day more and more
we have to rely upon the intelligence of
machines to be able to do that type of
analysis one of the largest areas that
we've been investing in is what you know
everybody refers to as machine learning
or artificial intelligence and it's most
sort of simplistic what it is is it's us
working with the machines to train them
right this is a picture of a clustering
algorithm that's grouped different types
of malware based on the behaviors that
those apple
exhibit out there in the world and so
when we're looking at 500,000 new
applications every day a clustering out
of them gives us the ability to quickly
hone in on the ones that we think are
highest risk those may be applications
that are brand new that no one's has
installed those may be applications that
have been out there for a while that
we're starting to see a change in their
behavior right the key is using these
systems to understand and make those
kinds of quick decisions so that a user
doesn't have to make them so that you as
a developer don't have to make them
either and you don't have to guess
because you can rely upon the
investments that we're making to analyze
all those data points and help make
those decisions for you and inform you
about what's going on on these devices
the other thing that we've begun to
recognize is sometimes we just name
things wrong there's a feature that we
released a couple of years ago called
Android device manager how many people
had Android device manager installed for
this audience it's about 20% so you
you're about an order of magnitude
higher than the the overall user base in
terms of percentage of people that had
Android device manager installed not
shocking given who we are and how many
of you are Googlers no okay find my
device a simple way to take an existing
set of technology expose it to users and
make it easier for them to understand
how it is that they can get to it and of
course we've added new features things
like battery and Wi-Fi status tracking
the device in the background so that if
it gets turned off you know where it was
before it was turned off you don't have
to do the query in real time a number of
sort of basic usability features to make
sure that this functionality can be
increasingly valuable for users because
after all the most significant security
risks that the average person is exposed
to is actually this one it's losing
their device whether it's accidental or
whether it's someone taking the device
out of their possession the other thing
we wanted to do is just let people know
that this was happening right the number
of times that I've read the statement
Google doesn't look at the applications
in Google Play it blows my mind every
single application that's uploaded to
Google Play goes through a very rigorous
screening process both at the time that
the application is developer is
enrolling to become a member of sort of
Google Play publishing process and at
the time the application is published
and
every single day after that we reanalyze
all of those applications so it's
absolutely a lot of that kind of
intelligence that's going on in the
background and analysis going on in the
background it simply wasn't exposed and
so a lot of the work that we're doing
right now is to just figure out how to
delicately indicate to the user whether
that be a consumer or an enterprise yeah
this is happening we're checking these
things and we've got your back but it's
not just about consumers right it's also
about application developers and making
sure that they have the ability to
leverage these services as well right
now Google Play services is rolling out
a new version and one of the api's
that's exposed is what we refer to as
the verify apps API in the past we've
talked publicly about verify apps which
is the mechanism that's used to evaluate
on a device and to check for a user on a
device whether something is potentially
harmful or a piece of malware what we've
done with the verify apps API is just
made that available to any application
on the device so if you're concerned
about whether or not your application
should be running you can check are
there any other apps on this device that
I should be worried about what are those
applications let me know what they are
and so then you can evaluate whether or
not you think it's an appropriate
environment as the application developer
for your application to continue to
execute that builds on other
technologies that we've provided in the
past last year at Google i/o I
referenced the safety net attestation
API this is an API that we use to
evaluate in the context of Google's
understanding of a dice whether it is a
certified secure Android device and we
provide that literally as a signed
statement right so you invoke the
attestation API it hits a round-trip off
of a Google server we do an evaluation
of the software integrity on that device
compared to what we know about what that
device should look like and then they
can statement back to you yep this looks
good or no it doesn't right this is one
of the critical pieces of technology
that allows for delivery for example
Android pay where there's a requirement
that this be a certified device and
that'll be operating in that kind of
environment but it's an API that we've
made available to any application that
wants to take advantage of it we're
going to continue adding these kinds of
technologies reCAPTCHA with the
technology introduced almost ten years
ago in the context of the web to do
quick evaluation of whether or not the
entity interacting with your
webui was actually a human that's now
being provided as a safety net api as
well so in the context of your
application you can use a reCAPTCHA to
evaluate whether or not there's
automation of your application right
this is particularly valuable for what I
think of as low cost services that you
want to continue to make available for
free but you want to cut down on the
amount of abuse that's coming through
bot farms and other types of automation
right very valuable for large scale web
properties one of the things that's come
out of us being able to understand
what's going on at the ecosystem is the
ability to revisit some of the
technologies that are actually baked
into the core platform unknown sources
was a flag that was introduced when
Android was launched almost eight years
ago
that gave the individual the ability to
change where they wanted to install
applications from over the last few
years we've begun to understand what
those install patterns look like we've
been able to analyze what the risks are
that users are exposed to we've
certainly come to appreciate that Google
Play is a safer place to install
applications from but we've also come to
appreciate that there are many other
safe places to install applications from
as well and so we want to simplify for
the user the ability to install from
those other safe places without
introducing the risk of installing from
just anywhere that's out there so one of
the changes that was introduced with
Android o is a modification to how
unknown sources works so now it's on a
per application basis you decide yep
that App Store it can install but that
doesn't mean everybody can install and
really that's targeted at making sure
that apps are being installed for more
trustworthy places where the user has
delegated that kind of trust to the
specific entity so that's an example of
the types of changes that we're making
at the platform level
I've got Shou in here I think is going
to come on up and give you a little bit
of insight into some of the other
changes we're making to harden the
operating system Thank You Adrian
my name is Shallon I am the product
manager for Android platform security
and today and this next section will
talk I'd like to give you an overview of
the changes that we've made to the
operating system to make it more secure
as well as the hardness we've collected
a lot of data on the impact and the
adoption of some of these features so
I'm excited to share some of that with
you so let's dig in
we'll start with the basics
and that begins with verified boots so
verified boot is androids secure boot
mechanism where we check the signature
of every stage of boots before running
us and that has come a long way in the
last few years with Android marshmallow
we started requiring a verified boot for
all compatible devices with Android
nougats that became verified boot is now
strictly enforced and that's required
for all compatible devices and now with
Android oh we're providing guidance to
our equals to our OEM ecosystem to add a
couple more security enhancements to
really round out the features that a
verified boot starting with roll back
protections with on compatible devices
on Android Oh verified boots will no
longer boot and operating systems that's
known to has been rolled back to an
older potentially a much more vulnerable
version also with verified boot we have
hardened the unlocking mechanism the
bootloader a locking mechanism and what
that means is any bugs or any compromise
in the Android operating system cannot
unlock the bootloader only you by
interacting with the bootloader itself
can unlock the bootloader
so while verify boots protect your
operating system Android uses encryption
to protect user data and that has also
come a long way in the last few years as
a van joint marshmallow all compatible
devices are now required to support
encryption and could require to be
enabled by default as of Android nougat
we added a major upgrade to encryption
story called file based encryption where
we encrypt different storage areas with
different keys
Sallah based encryption made the user
experience of encryption much much
better without sacrificing security as
an app developer in fact if you are
interested in running your app before
the first the user first signs in before
the user first unlocks their device
check out our SP documentation on our
developer website with Android oh we
have continued to improve on SBE and add
it in a few more features such as key
ejection so how are we doing it with
encryption we looked into the data and
see that over the last few years
encryption on Android we've seen a
significant adoption flaws on android
march on Android lollipop devices
encryption was very very low marshmallow
that jumped to about 25 percent and now
in Android nougat we're seeing
encryption support at around 80 percent
as a matter of fact we started requiring
encryption on compatible devices as of
Android marshmallow the reason that
number didn't jump immediately to 100%
is due to a couple of factors one is a
lot of marshmallow devices or upgrades
from lollipop and so those devices were
not required to be encrypted when they
first shipped and also because of the
wide variety of devices that are
supported by Android we still see a lot
of very low performance devices that are
not yet capable of supporting encryption
nevertheless we could expect that number
to continue to increase and we see that
encryption on Android is now the norm
and no longer the exception another way
in which we are protecting user data is
to improve the secure lock screen
experience with Android marshmallow we
introduced official support for
fingerprint sensors and that had a
significant impact on the adoption rate
of a secure lock screen also we have
been working with manufacturers to put
on requirements to make the
implementation of a secure lock screen
much more secure over time from the very
beginning fingerprint implementation the
fingerprint verification was required to
be implemented in secure hardware such
as the trusted execution environment the
PE with Android Mugen we started require
in that pin pattern password
verification also take place in secure
hardware and now with Android oh we're
adding in support for tamper resistant
hardware so similar to the chip that you
see in credit cards today Android now
supports having that should be embedded
in the in the hardware and using that
chip to do pin pattern password
verification the significantly raises
the bar makes it much much harder to
perform a physical attack against the
device to put to bypass the lock screen
so how are we doing with secure
lockscreen adoption we see that that has
also increased quite a bit over the last
few years
whereas on lollipop devices adoption was
only about half and half that increase
to almost 70 percent now on new Android
Newgate devices and a lot of that was
probably driven by the fact that a lot
of new devices now have a fingerprint
sensor and we see from the data that
fingerprint devices are much more likely
to have a skier lockscreen than across
the entire Android device system device
market the other thing is that we do see
apps such as Android pay and some
enterprise apps require enabling a
secure lock screen to a function
properly so that might also have had in
effect as developers you might want to
consider taking really really take
advantage of the lock screen and
incorporating that into your own
application so we see a lot of banking
apps for example incorporating
fingerprint authentication so while
encryption and lock screen protects user
data enjoy it has a robust permission
model to give users control over app
access to their data and that has also
improved quite a bit over the last few
years with Android marshmallow we
introduced runtime permissions and we've
seen great adoption there with Android
Mugen and Android oh we are continuing
to update the permissions model to make
it more usable by good apps and less
abusable by bad apps so before we go
into the details of that let's check out
how runtime permissions are doing
we looked into
permission requests and so for each
request for let's say the camera group
of permissions we see that about 65% of
users 65% of those requests are accepted
by the users so that's towards one at
the end of the spectrum towards the
other end of the spectrum we see that
for the phone group of permissions only
about 44% of the permission requests are
accepted by the user so users are
actually very judicious in controlling
which apps have access to what data so I
think that a couple of takeaways here
for apps the big thing is of course the
follow of permissions best practices so
you can take a really take advantage of
runtime permissions to provide the best
user experience as an example you should
always make sure that users know why
you're asking for a particular
permission and be able to fail
gracefully if they decline that
permission request in some cases you may
not need to ask for permission for
example you may be able to use the
contact sticker instead of requesting
the contacts permission another way
which we are updating our permissions
model is to make it less usable by bad
apps so take ransomware as an example
we've seen instances of this type of
malware that take over your device and
then - and then demand payment before
they let you back in and they typically
abuse two permissions first they use the
system alert window permission to
display an overview overlay on top of
your entire screen so that you can't
interact properly with a with your with
your device to address that an Android
oh we have changed the system alert
window permission slightly so that
overlays apple relays can no longer
cover up critical system windows so they
can no longer cover up the lock screen
they cannot cover up the status bar and
they cannot cover up the IME as examples
also when there's an overlay that's
being an app overlay that's being shown
there will also be a notification that
users can click on to hide that overlay
window ransomware also take advantage of
the device admin permission they use it
to prevent their own uninstall and they
use it to change your passcode so you to
lock you out of your device
over the last few years we have been
continually be scoping a device admin
permission and replacing it with a less
abusable alternative in particular in
android nougat bad apps can now no
longer use the device admin permission
to prevent their own uninstall and they
can't use it to change your passcode if
you already have one set to learn more
we actually have a a talk one of our
co-workers gave at a different
conference so check that out another way
in which we've updated a permissions
model in order to protect users is to
take a stronger stance on privacy over
the last few releases of Android we've
been steadily removing access to
persistent device identifiers so for
example in Android Oh the Android ID
property is now scoped per user and per
app the net cell hostname property which
contains the network host name of your
device is now empty to learn more about
the changes in Android Oh regarding
persistent device identifiers check out
the blog post that's on the on the
screen that will that will tell you all
the changes as well as the best
practices so everything I've talked
about so far relates to installed apps
so what about instant apps if you guys
were here in the last session actually
in this tent there was a session about
instant apps so it's an app for those
who don't know is a feature coming to
Android where you can click on a URL and
open it immediately in Android app even
if you don't have the app installed so
that has a potential to greatly improve
user experience as well as increase in
apps user engagement and conversion
numbers on the other hand opening up
arbitrary URLs and apps also comes with
associated security and privacy risks so
how do we want to address that we are
addressing that by creating an updated
permissions model that's really tailored
to the capabilities and characteristics
of an android instant app in particular
instant apps will have curative priority
best practices based on
for example instant apps must use
runtime permissions and instant apps
will use HTTP instead of HTTP by default
there are a lot of Android permissions
that instead ups actually cannot access
they cannot access any persistent
persistent device identifiers and
another example is that they can't
access the contacts permission you must
use the contact picker instead as app
developers if you make your normal apps
deployable is it instant up but it
actually makes your normal app much
better too because you're now
automatically using security and privacy
best practices and for users if the
majority of your apps are now using
these best practices then your device
becomes a little bit safer too so we're
very excited about the insane apps model
so while permissions is really a way to
control app access to data within the
operating system itself we use we said
box and isolate every process in every
app to limit the ways in which a
compromise in one can affect the others
for many years in Android we have been
up we have been steadily improving the
application sandbox in force with
selinux and we'll see how that's doing
the next slide in Android nougat we
applied these same sandboxing principles
to the media server to significantly
hardness and now in an annoyed Oh with
project trouble we are taking isolation
to the next level by putting device
specific vendor components into their
own sand boxes so how are we doing there
we looked into the data into the Android
Security Bulletin data from the first
four months of this year when I said all
the kernel bugs and we see that about
half of the kernel bugs almost half as
the Linux actually we do some severity
of almost half of those kernel bugs by
making posters of the kernel unreachable
by untrusted apps we made it so that
it's much harder to exploit those parts
of the kernel and that's what selinux
really helps with
as I mentioned earlier we took the same
sandboxing and isolation techniques and
applied it to the media server in older
versions of Android the media server
used to be this one giant monolithic
very complex process that had access to
a lot of permissions an Android n we
wrote that up into six different
processes and put them into individual
sand boxes with much tighter permissions
so that a compromise to any one of them
only grants access to a small subset of
the permissions and not the permissions
of the entire media server we also
integrated integer overflow sanitization
into the media server where we're able
to detect memory over memory corruption
that results from integer overflows this
helped us find a lot more bugs earlier
in a development process and limited the
severity of any bugs that occur at one
time so how do we do there we looked
into the the bugs ledger security
bulletin bugs from the first four months
of this year and we see that of all
media staff bugs that affected Android
marshmallow more than 20% of them
actually are no longer security issues
in Android N and a few more bugs on top
of that downgraded in severity from
marshmallow to N and we're not done yet
so in Android oh we we took sandbox and
isolation to a whole new level with
project trouble with project trouble
we're putting Android the Android OS
framework and the venerable notation of
the device specific vendor
implementation into different processes
that communicate with each other using
the standard vendor interface this
vendor interface will be maintained from
version of version which means a newer
Android OS framework will run with
minimal changes on top of an older
device and that paves the way then for
us to release new Android OS framework
versions with shiny new features and new
security enhancements and have it be
adopted much more quickly by the entire
ecosystem so that's very very exciting
for security
also the end of the vendor interface
allows us to enforce the boundaries
between the framework and the vendor
implementation so that we can use it to
limit the ways in which a bug in one can
affect the other to take an example
let's go back to the media server as
part of project trouble we have re
architected the media server again in
Android L and taken the audio camera and
DRM hardware abstraction layers and put
them into different processes in
different sandboxes what that lets us do
is to say the framework pieces actually
now no longer need access to the kernel
components the kernel drivers that
control media playback and so now we can
put the framework of pieces also into
tighter sand boxes as well and make it
so that an exploit in the kernel
compromising the kernel it's not much
harder for that compromise to exploit
certain areas of the four it's now
harder for compromises in the framework
to exploit certain areas of the kernel
all right so speaking of the kernel
why is kernel why is the kernel
important in the last year we have spent
a lot of time hardening the kernel and
we did that for one major reason we see
that kernel bugs are becoming a much
larger proportion of android security
bugs was in 2014 about 4% of android
security bugs for kernel bugs that
number increased significance ignition
out forty four percent and there are
probably a couple reasons for this one
is we've made a lot of progress in
hardening the user space so for example
the application sandbox that's enforced
by icy Linux that's done a lot better
over time and in order to break out of
that application sandbox in order to
break out of the isolytic sandbox you
have to compromise the kernel also the
kernel is very powerful has large attack
surface it's kind of like the king piece
in a game of chess
you take the kernel and you win the game
and so we decided to spend a lot more
time thinking about how to harden
carnal so we looked into what causes
kernel bugs we looked into the data from
2014 and 2016 and categorize different
kernel bugs into in different categories
and we see that the largest category
accounting for about 45% is this missing
an incorrect bounce check when we're
copying data from user space to the
kernel so we presented this exact same
data to the Linux upstream community and
to arm last year and to their credit
they were super responsive within a
couple of months they gave us a feature
called hardened user copy that addresses
this an entire category of kernel bugs
so we have since then back ported
hardened user copy to the edge or
kernels 318 and above and we have also
implemented a few more security features
on top of that we have implemented 10
emulation we have implemented Kas LR and
many others so all of these kernel
features taken together we expect that
they will have a huge impact on the
number and severity of kernel bugs in
the future another way in which we are
protecting the kernel is to reduce its
attack surface we're using a technology
called seccomp
to enforce a whitelist of system calls
that apps can use to communicate with
the colonel any system calls that are
not on that whitelist will be blocked by
the second filter so everything that's
on the white list that includes system
calls that are made by all public
libraries that is supported in android
so and we have tested many of the top
apps as well as google apps so we expect
that this actually won't impact almost
any app but if you do have an app that
uses a user's a lot of native code we do
encourage you to test that up on an
android device to make sure that any
system calls that you make are not
affected by the new second filter having
this whitelist of kernel interfaces
allows us to really focus and
concentrate our testing and Quality
Assurance efforts on
while defined a whitelist and also be
sure be more confident that the rest of
the kernel is protected and that is much
harder to exploit the rest of the kernel
SEC hope is actually not new to Android
Chrome has been using it for quite a
while in fact so chrome has their own
app defined second filter around the
renderer process they use this second
filter to make a few guarantees they
want to guarantee that the regular
process can read global space but it
cannot modify a global state and in fact
this has been quite useful in quite a
few times recently we've seen a few
kernel bugs that were actually
unreachable from the chrome renderer
process because the relevant system
calls were blocked by seccomp okay so
that was a really quick overview of the
updates of the security relevant updates
in the Android OS let's now turn to app
security in particular we'll talk about
a couple of features that improve the
security of your apps first let's go
over what view so what view has been
with Android since the very beginning it
shipped up until KitKat it shipped with
the operating system which means that
there were any bugs in webview it
actually was not very easy for us to fix
those bugs and get them out to users
quickly we address that with Android
lollipop when we made webview a separate
apk that is updatable every six weeks by
the Play Store and now with Android oh
we've added quite a bit more a few more
security features to webview in
particular the webview renderer process
similar to how it works on chrome now
runs as an isolated process separate
from the rest of your app this means
that any crashes or any compromises to
the renderer process no longer really
affects your app and any website that is
able to exploit the webview process
can't easily use that to exploit the
rest of your
the rendering process in fact is put
into a very very tight sandbox using set
comp and other technologies for example
I cannot write to the network on its own
talk to the network on its own or write
to disk on its own and so that also
protects the rest of the operating
system for many exports and what in
webview in the render process another
cool feature coming to webview is Safe
Browsing
so Safe Browsing has been available on
Chrome for quite a long time when users
visit a website that's known to be
malicious Safe Browsing will show a
warning and prompt the user before
continuing Safe Browsing has been
showing showing useful warnings to users
more than 250 million times for months
and now it's coming to webview on
Android safe browsing is actually
implemented within the webview apk
that's updatable every six weeks by the
Play Store and so you can actually
change your app and protect your users
almost immediately another important
aspect of app security is device and
user authentication so why is device
authentication important well if you're
using a phone to buy things or to unlock
your home door you want to make sure
that no-one can pretend to be your phone
and so what you can do is you can use
the Android key store API is to generate
a key pair to uniquely identify your
device the benefit using the key store
API is that on new Android devices key
store keys are protected by secure
hardware such as this trusted execution
environment and so even in the event of
a kernel compromise no one can extract
out those skis and clothe them onto
another device there was always one
question remaining though which is how
do you actually know that those keys are
properly protected let's say you're you
know you're on the server side how does
your server verify that you're that
you're talking to a device that's using
keys that are properly protected by
secure home where this is where key
access patient comes in with Android oh
or adding in and a sensation API for
compatible devices we're at a high level
you're you
or server can talk directly to the
secure hardware the charts at execution
environment on the device and ask you to
give you signed assertions about the
properties of the keys that it protects
as well as about the properties of the
device so for example the key a
cessation API can tell you whether the
key itself actually is protected by this
puro hardware it can also tell you for
example whether verified boot paths on a
particular device the associated
association certificate chain on
compatible device is actually rooted in
a Google certificate so that's how you
know that that device itself is known at
Google and is compatible with Google
standards alright so that was device
authentication so what about user
authentication we're happy to let you
let everyone know that with the next
version of Google Play services we're
also adding API to support site Oh
YouTube security keys as you probably
know security keys or second faster
tokens that are already accepted by many
major web sites such as Google Facebook
github and security keys as compared to
traditional second factor methods are
faster to authenticate and harder to
fish so we know that for a lot of users
one of the most important things that
they can do to secure their user
accounts is to enable second factor
authentication so we're very excited
that security key support is coming in
Android so to wrap up we covered a lot
of material we talked about all kinds of
improvements in the operating system we
talked about app security if you want to
learn more about making your app more
secure check out these developer
resources we have a checklist as well as
some best practices we also have a
couple of code labs here at i/o that you
can try out at the kiosks or you can try
out online so thank you for your
attention and if you have questions or
any comments feel free to email us at
security at Android comm and will also
be backstage thank you
[Applause]
[Music]